burkina faso el descontento con el
gobierno se sintió en las calles acusan
al presidente rock kaboré de fracasar en
su lucha contra la violencia de
militantes islamistas
desde que él está en el poder los
terroristas están sembrando la
desolación en este país y él es incapaz
de encontrar una solución a este
problema por eso le pedimos su renuncia
inmediata hoy y ahora mientras no
renuncie no iremos a casa
la policía disolvió la protesta con
gases lacrimógenos en respuesta al
movimiento antigubernamental que lleva
varios meses activos las autoridades
cortaron el acceso a internet móvil hace
una semana y se negaron a autorizar la
manifestación de este sábado hace dos
semanas militantes vinculados al qaeda
mataron a 49 policías además de cuatro
civiles en la ciudad de innata al norte
del país
los ataques han alimentado el
descontento contra el gobierno y también
contra las fuerzas militares francesas
que lo apoyan en su lucha personal
siempre personalmente creo que cambiar
de presidente nunca ha resuelto ningún
problema siempre genera otros problemas
mando
llegada lo que pedimos es echar a
francia de áfrica porque cuando vemos
que hay bases militares francesas en
áfrica estos países siempre tienen
problemas de ataque hace cinco años
francia lucha en la región contra
militantes de al-qaeda y el estado
islámico pero la inestabilidad política
ha socavado la lucha regional contra
estos grupos terroristas el presidente
prometió cambios en el gobierno y el
ejército para intentar remediar la
crisis mientras los extremistas ganan
terreno en la región del sahel de áfrica
occidental